[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM DAVIS: Dance Like
enables you to learn
how to dance on a mobile phone.
CHRIS MCCLANAHAN: TensorFlow
can take our smartphone camera
and turn it into a powerful
tool for analyzing body pose.
ANDREW SELLE: We
have team at Google
that had developed
an advanced model
for doing pose segmentation.
So we were able to take
their implementation,
convert it into TensorFlow Lite.
Once we had it there, we
could use it directly.
SHIKHAR AGARWAL: To run all
the AI and machine learning
models to detect
body parts, it's
a very computationally
expensive process,
where we need to use
the on-device GPU.
TensorFlow library
made it possible so
that we can leverage all
these resources, the compute,
on the device and give
a great user experience.
ANDREW SELLE: Teaching
people to dance
is just the tip of the iceberg.
Anything that involves movement
would be a great candidate.
TIM DAVIS: And so that
means people who have skills
can teach other
people those skills.
And AI is just this layer
that really just interfaces
between the two things.
When you empower
people to teach people,
I think that's really
when you have something
that is game changing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]